one of the things that's most peculiar
about life in the developed economies in
our own time is the way we look at work
and in particular the way we think that
work should be about two things making
money of course but also in far more
strangely finding fulfillment creativity
and meaning it's a beautiful idea of
course but it's also a highly unusual
one which causes us quite a few
headaches as well it's worth taking a
look into the history of work the Garden
of Eden 3900 BC according to Christian
doctrine when Adam and Eve are expelled
from the Garden of Eden for eating an
apple that punishment for defying God's
wishes is work by the sweat of your brow
you will eat your food until you return
to the ground the Lord informs them work
is what distinguishes life in Paradise
from the world we know Adam will have to
work until he is 930 years old Athens
335 BC Aristotle opens his public school
the Lyceum a center of learning for
wealthy and cultured young Athenians
Aristotle makes a bold claim
the life of the mind is only open to
rich people
anyone who has actually to earn money to
live is a slave Aristotle tells us
however out would be grand their life
might be the pursuit of money and good
intellectual work is simply impossible
the philosopher declares and he's widely
believed for hundreds of years
Hippo Roman Africa 396 ad st. Augustine
becomes the Bishop of Hippo and in his
sermons resurrects the Christian notion
of work as a result of original sin in
his sermons on the New Testament
Augustine tells his audience many of
whom are slaves that work is always
going to be miserable from this cup of
sorrow no one may be excused the cup
that Adam has pledged must be drunk the
only relief is to look forward to the
next life in God's kingdom
Rome 1508 the Florentine painter
sculptor architect and poet Michelangelo
begins painting the ceiling of the
Sistine Chapel commissioned by Pope
Julius ii he is given complete freedom
to design the work and promised a lot of
money in return Michelangelo along with
his fellow Italian genius Leonardo da
Vinci embody a new approach to work they
work for money hiring out their talents
to the highest bidders in the courts of
Europe but they're evidently not slaves
at the same time they don't work just
for the money they do it for the
inherent fulfillment that the work
brings our modern ideas of work are a
lot the Renaissance idea of the
remunerative creative genius our own
ambitions are now democratized versions
of the aspirations of men like Leonardo
and Michelangelo we too wish to be paid
and creative Wittenberg Holy Roman
Empire 1520 Martin Luther the founder of
Protestantism makes the momentous point
that one can serve God through work of
many different kinds and not just as it
previously been argued by Catholicism
simply by entering the priesthood he
proposes that the common work of a
servant or a handmaiden can be more
acceptable to God than all the fastings
and works of a monk or a priest God is
milking the cows through the vocation of
the milkmaid for Luther God has endowed
each one of us with talents that can be
used to help one another out which is
how work becomes moral everyone
undertaking essential tasks he mentions
cleaning milking darning teaching is
wearing what youth are calls the mask of
God since God is behind each task this
Luther says demonstrates God's love he
ensures that we're endowed with the
qualities to look after one another
through our work work for Luther is
therefore the best means to employ the
doctrine of love thy neighbor
Protestantism is responsible for a
momentous revaluation of the Worth and
dignity of ordinary laborer Paris France
1750 Diderot and Dalembert published the
first volume of their aussi clock ad
which sets out to cover each and every
branch of human work there's one chapter
in which Diderot writes with particular
Admiral
about bakers there are others on the
work of farmers bell makers locksmiths
and cloth weavers it's the longest
illustrated poem in praise of ordinary
work ever written and it has a huge
impact on how people perceive the
prestige of work
Paris France 1844 the exiled Karl Marx
finishes his economic and philosophical
scripts of 1844 a series of notes on
capitalism containing some of his most
interesting thinking about work he
attacks capitalism not because workers
don't get paid enough or are exploited
but for a far more interesting reason
because too often their work is boring
and it doesn't allow them to develop
their characters that's the true problem
with capitalism in Marx's eyes marx who
works 12 hours a day most days is no
enemy of work what infuriates him about
capitalism is that it seems to prevent
us from enjoying our work enjoying it as
much as he enjoyed his because it
encourages the production of goods
disconnected from the talents and
aspirations of the worker that's what he
so desperately wishes to correct
communism isn't a project for getting
rid of work it's about making work more
enjoyable University of Chicago USA 1899
an irritable American academic publishes
his first book the theory of the leisure
class in it Thorstein Veblen captures
very clearly an idea of being
upper-class that's about to die out
forever fable and argues that as soon as
people make it in society they try to
show their superiority by displaying
signs of what leisure rich and idle
people they are vey bland writes that
the characteristic feature of the rich
is a conspicuous exemption from useful
employment avaible and may well be right
for his own day that everything is about
to change within a few decades everyone
falls prey to a new cult the cult of
working hard and being very very busy
all the time soon only the unemployed
are idle everyone else is working away
furiously the richer you are the more
you keep working to show that you're
good and serious being idle is the new
taboo Washington DC USA 1945 with work
newly prestigious one of the major
challenges of society's become
that of correctly mining the talents of
everyone and helping them to find their
way into the right jobs that is jobs
that will fulfill them and make the
money Katharine cook Briggs and her
daughter Isabel Briggs Myers run the
first Briggs Myers indicator test on
George Washington Medical School
students this test developed throughout
the Second World War
indicates personality types and tries to
pair people up with ideal jobs the test
uses 93 questions to figure out which
one of four main personality types you
might be introverts extroverts thinkers
feelers sensors intuitive's judges
perceivers so for example an introvert
will enjoy thinking and working alone or
in small peaceful groups and will be
suited to working as an accountant a
dentist or a librarian but an extrovert
will enjoy action dominated high-octane
work and might go into acting
salesmanship or trading in financial
institutions the goal Briggs & Myers say
is to find the type of work that suits
you best work is about making the
correct lifestyle choice just suit your
personality it's not about arbitrary
aims such as money living rooms USA
January 22nd 1984 Apple computers
launches the only national airing of its
famous 1984 advert during the halftime
commercials of the Super Bowl the
60-second advert sees a heroine dressed
in bright running gear save an army of
soulless workers from the conformity of
standardized work by destroying their
big brother like leader
it's an idea as old as the Renaissance
there's good work and bad work and the
good work is the creative kind except
now unlike in Michelangelo's day thanks
to technology this is for everyone
the advert carried the famous tag line
you'll see why 1984 won't be like 1984
the advert underlined the liberating
colorful and energetic Mac as a
deliverance from the technophobic
drudgery of industrial labour the future
of work is going to be fun original and
expressive in Apple's hands but for
millions of the unemployed or the
unhappily employed the dream has not
turned out to be so easy it can be
doubly painful when you're meant to be
having such fun at work to find no work
at all or work that doesn't fulfill your
soul the modern world has made the
career crisis one of the central
difficulties of existence we're asking
so much
our working lives so no wonder they
sometimes don't deliver against the
expectations that we now have of them
too often our jobs are closer to the
toil of Adam than the life enhancing
creativity of Michelangelo that remains
the challenge for the future of work
you